Salvador Dali's gift for self-publicity made him the first art superstar...
...of the television age.
Regarded by some of his peers as a sellout...
...who didn't toe the line politically,...
...he first made his name with art...
...that mind his deepest fears and fixations.
These surrealist paintings owed much...
...to the theories of psychoanalysis,...
...but there's more to Dali than these skillfully rendered...
...fever dreams of sex and decay.
He painted one of the 20th century's great crucifixions,...
...but it's more about physics than religion...
...and he was as influenced by philosophy as he was by Sigmund Freud.
He strove to depict the unseen from the movement of atoms...
...to the concept of a fourth dimension.
It was one of the many interests he shared...
...with his friend, Marcel Duchamp.
Dali once said he would never really die.
It's a sort of grandiose state that he was famous for,...
...but it has a ring of truth for his enduring fame...
...and his impact on popular culture has given him a kind of immortality.